The evp program bears the Union's signature in Germany and what
we have adopted here today is a clear message to voters in Germany for freedom,
for security,
but also for prosperity and thus for competitiveness in our industry,
of course,
maintaining.
All targets thus 1.
Approach,
in particular,
to manage climate change,
to achieve the Paris goals.
But we are also saying very clearly and very clearly that this can
only be done with a strong economy,
with a competitive industry.
Then we can 1.
Building a Strong Social Europe.
Then we can also contribute to climate change from Europe,
to solving this great problem of mankind.
And that is our intention.
And we have formulated this here today in great agreement.